henri emmanuelli bonsoir venez
d'entendre le rpr philippe seguin rendre
hommage à l'action des premiers
ministres socialistes qu'est ce que
concrètement on peut faire pour
améliorer la vie publique aux des mois
j'ai d'emblée lorsque monsieur seguin a
constitué son groupe je lui fais une
lettre en disant que pour nous les deux
choses essentielles y en a d'autres mais
c'était le financement public c'est à
dire arrêtez de financement par les
entreprises totalement totalement je
constate que c'est dans le texte de
conclusions diminuer le montant des
campagnes électorales je constate que ça
y figurent aussi et puis rétablir les
dispositions anti corruption que
monsieur balladur et sa majorité avaient
enlevé et je constate que ça il figure
aussi à ce propos hier soir monsieur
balladur n'a pas dit la vérité aux
français quand il a dit que ces deux
dispositions concernées juste les
transports scolaires il faut pas oublier
de dire que ça concernait aussi les
renouvellement de concession en
particulier concession de l'eau je n'en
dis pas plus n'est ce pas et que ça
concernait aussi la transparence
lorsqu'une collectivité locale tu à dire
la publicité lorsqu'une collectivité
locale faisant des terrains je remarque
que monsieur besson est en train de
réintroduire sa part un amendement sur
la loi pasqua mais monsieur balladur n'a
pas dit la vérité et je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui lorsqu'il dit il faut
pas que ce soient les contribuables qui
paient que ce soit les entreprises les
entreprises ne donnerons d'argent qu'au
parti de droite et de toute façon ce
sont les français qui paient il ne faut
pas se faire d'illusions moi je souhaite
que ça se passe dans la transparence et
donc pas le financement public
d'ailleurs pas le seul sujet sur lequel
monsieur balladur n'a pas dit la vérité
on va y revenir dans un instant sur le
plan politique générale soit juste
encore un mot sur sur les affaires vous
même
vous avez eu à faire aujourd hui rec si
ça c'est vraiment ça a marché comme
monsieur balladur dit depuis que je suis
là la justice peut agir écoutez moi je
peux témoigner qu'elle agissait avant au
cas où il salua vous avez été mises en
examen pas au sérieux richard heck pour
en tant que trésorier du ps et mis en
examen deux jours j'ai été mis en examen
non pas parce qu'on me reprochait
personnel dans des faits mais parce que
j'ai été trésorier du parti socialiste
et qu'on reprochait au parti socialiste
final on en financement par un bureau
d'étude je dois dire que vu ce qui s'est
passé depuis tout ça apparaît que peu
dérisoire est ce que vous estimez que
les juges comme comme le sujet andré bec
vont trop loin par contre quand il
décide d'incarcérer un ministre est ce
que vous redoutez un gouvernement des
juges comme certains lots de moi je ne
redoute pas un gouvernement des juges je
ne souhaite pas non plus je crois que le
pouvoir dans ce pays appartient au
suffrage universel aux françaises et aux
français et à personne d'autre a dit
privatives pas plu au juge d'ailleurs
que vous pourrez exécuter vos pouvoirs
législatifs à me souverain dans ce pays
c'est le peuple suffrage universel
salpêtre personne d'autre est ce qu'il
ya eu une appréciation que vous ayez
reçu positivement dans tout ce qu'a dit
hier le premier ministre sur notre
antenne oui quand il a dit j'ai des
remords et des regrets d'avoir
supprimé des dispositions mises en place
par le gouvernement précédent sur la
détention provisoire finalement il aura
suffi qu'un ministre soit mis en
détention provisoire pour que monsieur
balladur et des regrets des remords
j'aurais préféré qu'il est d'une prise
de conscience
plus prématurés
sinon je vous ai coupé tout à l'heure le
reste je vais entendu dire hier soir la
france va mieux et moi je pense qu'il
faut une certaine audace ou avoir des
français une assez piètre opinion pour
leur dire depuis 18 mois la france va
mieux parce que quand on regarde les
choses j'ai amené ici un petit tableau
voilà l'évolution du chômage depuis
monsieur balladur arrive à ce moment là
voilà la courbe
j'ai amené un tableau sur l'évolution de
la dette publique parce qu'on nous
disait les socialistes ont ruiné la
france monsieur balladur arrive à ce
moment-là ici et on a une montée assez
spectaculaire de la dette de l'état et
puis j'entends des madame veil tout à
l'heure sur la sécurité sociale y est ça
va mieux tout va bien voilà ce qu'était
le déficit de la sécurité sociale
lorsqu'elle est arrivée au pouvoir qui
correspondait à cinq années de déficits
cumulés voilà ce qu'est le déficit dans
les trois années où madame weil le
monsieur balladur or ont gouverné la
france donc on est sans arrêt en
présence d'une présentation falsifiés de
la réalité qui consiste tout simplement
à gagner du temps en attendant les
présidentielles à l'esprit dans lequel
les français sommes dans le rang
précisément vous venez de faire allusion
à la présidentielle vous donnez une
transition toute trouvée dans un instant
nous allons évoquer cette séance à
gauche avec un turbulent silence comme
dirait andré brink celui de michel
rocard muet totalement nuit depuis son
départ de la tête du ps en juin que
devient un ancien secrétaire du ps et
que ce que l'on a baptisé l'arc a redit
les réseaux rocard vont ils se mettre au
service ou non de jacques delors réponse
avec ce reportage de guilaine chenu et
d'alain st
c'est un rituel chaque mardi michel
rocard des jeunes en compagnie de ses
plus proches conseillers a rendez vous
amical au menu l'actualité l'habitude
s'est installé à l'époque de matignon et
elle perdure malgré les revers
électoraux malgré le retrait politique
michel rocard on peut aussi l'apercevoir
à strasbourg où il s'acquitte de son
seul et unique mandat député européen
michel rocard travail mais ne parle plus
il y a un an il était le présidentiable
de gauche aujourd'hui ils cultivent
l'absence et apprend la solitude mais il
a gagné en liberté il n'est pas enfermé
dans un carcan n'est pas enfermée dans
le carcan du parti socialiste il est
libre donc à lui de décider quel est le
moment où il pourra revenir dans le
débat public au parti socialiste on ne
l'attend plus alors les rocardiens ont
repris le chemin de la minorité et sur
la route ils ont fait de nouvelles
rencontres martine aubry par exemple
certains proches de michel rocard
travaille déjà avec celle que l'on voit
comme une héritière
crédible travailler avec une
personnalité comme martine aubry c'est
continuer le même chemin c'est continuer
le même travail parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de points qui nous rapproche de la
manière de voir la politique à la
manière de présenter des idées et de
privilégier aujourd'hui dans le fond une
société solidaire contre une société
inégalitaire
larocca redis c'est aussi une machine
humaine ce sont des militants mais aussi
des experts des intellectuels réunis
dans des clubs de réflexion comme
convaincre bref des réseaux qui se
retrouvent avec des idées mais sans
candidat beaucoup de gens semblent bien
il peut encore apporter des choses à la
gauche et cela c'est aussi son impulsion
à lui donc on y travaille et savon pour
laisser les choses se faire doucement et
le réveil pourrait venir de lucelle si
jacques delors est candidat alors michel
rocard se dit prête à se mettre en
service de son ami et après 40 ans de
vie politique il pourrait devenir à
l'image d'un pierre mendès-france une
conscience morale
est-ce que selon vous michel rocard est
définitivement hors du jeu présidentiel
le reportage là n'était pas tout à fait
exact parce qu'il ya aussi des amis
michel roca qui travaillent avec moi la
direction observe qu'on en a pas parlé
je pense que michel rocard peut
conserver toutes ses chances c'est à lui
qu'il appartient effectivement comme ça
a été dit d'estimer un moment donné s'il
souhaite jouer un rôle s'il ne souhaite
pas mais moi je l' ai toujours dit
depuis le 19 juin je le répèterai et je
le vois de temps à autre alors les
méchantes langues il y en a les
mauvaises langues disent que seul seul
le ps pourrait empêcher jacques delors
d'être élu en mai prochain oui mais ce
sont toujours les mêmes méchante l'on
n'est ce pas ce sont ceux qui a ne sont
pas d'accord avec la direction actuelle
ce qui est leur droit d'ailleurs mais
qui dans en même temps ne veulent pas
l'affronter
et qui véhiculent comme cela des rumeurs
selon lesquelles moi je crois qu'il
aurait été plus simple pour celles et
ceux qui vécu ce genre de rumeur
d'aller au combat politique dans la
transparence et la clarté plutôt que de
véhiculer des choses inexactes enfin ça
fait partie des moeurs pauvre de la
capitale de l'or est votre candidat sans
état d'âme aux
candidats qui gagne et si jacques delors
est candidat les socialistes à mon sens
décideront de le soutenir en ville merci
je ne vous apprendrai rien en vous
signalant que françois mitterrand semble
bien décidé à resserrer ses liens avec
les socialistes